am montag findet am truppenübungsplatz
bruckneudorf eine gefechts vorführung
statt die soldaten erstürmen ein von
terroristen besetztes haus um die
leistungen der soldaten bei dieser übung
später einmal nachvollziehen zu können
sind alle soldaten und die teilnehmenden
fahrzeuge mit einem riesen gesteuerten
simulationssystem ausgestattet das sind
die ausbildungs geräte die auf den
waffen stationen aufgebaut werden von
unter verwendung von leser die wirkung
des eigenen waffensystems auf ein
anderes waffensystem und umgekehrt
simulieren jede bewegung und jede
schussabgabe wird von einem computer
erfasst und grafisch dargestellt bei
einem treffer wird das so genannte
ausfall sofort angezeigt
wie diese ausbildungs methode ist das
österreichische bundesheer im
internationalen vergleich ganz vorne mit
dabei
wodurch das gemeinsam mit trainieren in
kooperation mit anderen nationen
problemlos möglich ist auf militärische
seite wird dabei eher möglich dem
fünften der operativen kontext zusammen
mit ausländischen partner almer
darzustellen und ein komplettes umfeld
bis hin zu jedem zu daten abzumildern
und dann die unterschiedlichen kulturen
arbeitsweisen und verhaltensweisen
herauszuarbeiten und damit im
allfälligen einsatz bestens vorbereitet
zu sein das ziel was sie jeder
ausbildung gerade dieser ausbildung
besteht letztendlich ja darin den
soldatinnen und soldaten jene
fähigkeiten in die hand zu geben um
einen einsatz erfolgreich durchzuführen
und danach wieder unversehrt nach hause
zu kommen die gefechts vorführung mützen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
und die vizepräsidentin von sarah sagt
ekström zur vertragsunterzeichnung über
den ankauf von 100 setzen duell
simulatoren im wert von rund zehn
millionen euro
diese simulatoren werden unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten das heißt vom
grundwehrdiener über das kaderpersonal
bis hin zu den milizsoldaten auf eine
moderne
art und weise für mögliche einsätze
ausbilden und so auch zur
attraktivierung des dienstes beitragen
wir bewundern